era ora che succede
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video io sono faringei oggi siamo su
coldfusion indie horror che mi avete
consigliato in tanti non voglio stare
qui a fare promesse secolare quindi
iniziamo subito andiamo su play c'è un
elicottero giocattolo fantastico abbiamo
perso il contatto con gemini gemini il
nuovo programma di energia non mi fanno
a leggere magari capiamo la cosa non mi
fanno neanche leggere
abbiamo un team di ricerca che lavora in
segreto l'ultimo contatto erano vicini
all alt niente di niente non lo leggo
facciamo così tu sei da solo questo l'ho
capito guardati culo in piazza va beh
grazie grazie mille veramente
sviluppatori che pensano che io abbia la
capacità di leggere come un computer va
bene continuiamo a tenere ragazzi che
cosa tratta perché non ho visto nulla me
l'avete consigliate l'ho fatto e c'è
un'edicola abbiamo capito che a ok sono
posso già muovermi che figo se ne sta
andando l'elicottero che bello mi ha
lasciato in mezzo alla merda prove
penombra
va bè ragazzi siamo in mezzo ai pinguini
propri mettereste uscire a quello di
happy feet che balla ma le ragazze una
porta devo si corre qua devo camminare
tipo un bradipo per tutto il tempo si
devo camminare con bradipo ragazzi non è
colpa mia se sto comandando un obeso
alla razza che nella porta c'è il sangue
non va bene perché io non voglio entrare
qui dentro ma ci deve entrare
[Applauso]
io non ho toccato niente sia aperta da
sola e sentite io non voglio entrare qui
dentro anche perché c'è qualcuno la
zucca è steso a terra torna qui ho
dimenticato il cappello fa freddo raga
io posso finire qui il video datemi
l'autorizzazione per farlo ti prego non
voglio entrare dentro la porta già
indemoniata di suo
e vabbè permesso fa freddo fuori o entro
è sì grazie mille
secco ai colori aspetti raga e lo voglio
andare avanti scelta e mi scusi e mi
hanno mandato qui perché fa freddo sì
però se non voleva parlarmi poteva
dirmelo stupito è perché io sono stato
gentile ho chiesto permesso e c'è
nessuno vero nodo è dio mio astratto
dov'è andato a finire
vabbè andiamo andiamo in questa porta
che promette benissimo ragazzi è
fantastico perché non ho neanche la
terza ok però sia accesa la luce da solo
è a comando vocale
oppure mi devo preoccupare io opterei
per la seconda andiamo avanti
e richiesta la carta proprio l'apporto
che perfetto c'è una chiave da qualche
parte per aprire una tessera perfetto
quasi accendono le luci da sole dietro
non c'è nulla verrà lasciato niente a
diavoli club
andiamo a doverlo trascinato il corpo
giustamente allora ci sono dei detriti
ragazzi non è perché qua lampeggia tutto
dov'è andato il corpo di prima da
qualche parte dovrà pur essere vabbè ci
sono armadietti qui c'è qualcuno che ha
lasciato la merenda
io ho già fame c'era un club di prima e
c'è del sangue ovunque perfetto c'è
qualche la chiave l'ho trovata ho
trovato la tessera e cos'è la tessera
richiesta c'era la testa l'ho presa
adesso l'ho presa adesso si vede che
questa pre l'altra porta devo tornare
indietro anche qua ci sono fogli ovunque
e vengo così quaderni quando prendo
appunti o comunque va beh e torniamo
indietro dove c'era la porta di prima
ma ripensandoci tornerei anche dov'ero
prima sinceramente addio perché è caduto
un armadietto
vabbè acqua e per la norma l'armadietto
ragazzi devo andare la vecchia parte non
so dove ma devo uscire di qua già non mi
piace non ho capito raga bene perché si
chiama fusione a freddo sto gioco non ha
senso stone o me per per ora appunto
adesso non so se più avanti
scopriremo qualcosa praticamente non ho
fatto in tempo a leggere quasi accendere
la luce ogni volta mi devo prendere male
premi f per usare la chiave fi
apriti e rivela nuovi mondi e devo
andare non so dove
cosa cazzo successo
cos'è eri tu prima che strisciato
maledetto stronzo doveri ma dove si
caduto poi che non ci sono
aqua c'è un buco qui dove se eri
appiccicato a soffitto più poi su ingham
raga non mi piace per niente che cadono
i colpi dal soffitto non mi piace sta
cosa eh va beh noi proseguiamo ci sono
delle porte ragazzi perché mi
consigliate questi giochi perché non lo
capirò mai ma lo so perché perché mi
volete ma le cose si sta accendendo
qualcosa ci sta accendendo oddio cos'è
cos'è sta roba ucciderci un po di sangue
a terra nel caso non l'aveste notato è
c'è un'altra chiave perfetto ed è meglio
che vada avanti ragazze qualcos'altro di
quale altra porta chiusa con la chiave
spero sia questa perché non c'ho voglia
di tornare tutti indietro perfetto per
questa ma i ragazzi ci stiamo c'era
anche un'altra via rag all'inizio che
non ho visto poi quando tornano indietro
la vedrò ma che deve essere tutto così
ok c'è una chiave qui io la prendo e me
ne vado grazie mille
non lo so chi è stato ma io me ne vado
ragazzi benissimo e ho preso la chiave
quello mi interessava alla fine io me ne
vado grazie mille
no mi interessa chi ha lanciato il
tavolo non lo voglio sapere chiudi raga
sta diventando assurdo di preciso non so
che cosa devo fare penso sia una madonna
santissima
ma cosa dio mio
vis forca gas perfetto e c'era un
flagrant vera fame mi fanno schifo le
cose così buongiorno ceramica qualcuno
li non voglio sapere qualcosa visto che
di indietro non ci devo tornare guardo
avanti e prima di tornare a vedere se si
apre quella porta con la chiave nuova
devo vedere qualche non ci ho ancora
visto niente e niente un musical cos'è
sta roba
cos'è cos'è successo si è spenta la luce
via non mi piace quando si spengono le
luci
va bene allora me ne vado di qua va
benissimo non ci torno più e chiude
benissimo ragazzi spero di non doverci
più tornare lì tu potevi startene anche
fermo per quanto mi riguarda invece non
sei dovuto a strisciare maledetto
cos'è che adotta rai che cosa stai cosa
succede cosa non lo voglio sapere che
cos'è accaduto io vado avanti non perché
loro pretendono che io vada vedere
quando c'è un rumore ma io non ci vado a
vedere vado avanti allora c'è una chiave
d'oro alla piastra porta di prima e
spero di sì perché se non so dove andare
io lì non ci voglio andare perfetto si
apre lampeggia la luce fantastico già
iniziamo bene è una stanza chiusa
che cosa mi rappresenta una stanza che
trattano faccio un'altra chiave ok ci si
prende perfetto verrà qua con questa
dovrei riuscire a tornare indietro
dove c'era la porta prima chiusa che
c'era qualcosa dentro perché cesta
musica di suspense rega fatemi dare
soltanto un occhiata a destra prima
elettorali
aprite volevo neanche entrare io
preferivo stare al freddo abera caso e
qui ci dobbiamo entrare per forza
senti zio velino strisciare perché devi
farmi la guardia fai la guardia fammi un
fischio se passa qualcuno di me lo fa
qualcosa ma fa melo capire ara il tipo
di prima e andando verso di qua però non
ha la chiave per aprire la porta quindi
dovrei essere assicuri intervento
di sicuro lo sapevo che non era sicuro
lo sapevo cosa è accaduto
non lo so cos'è cadeau dottore che
apriamo stava le detta porta oh mio dio
santo cos'è cos'era quella roba lì non
lo so ma perché io quando parlo
succedono ste cose
se me ne stavo zitto e chiudi chiuri
chiriquì proprio perché qua non voglio
che passi il nessuno perché ci sono
altre vie come volevo nenè bastava una
cos'è sta roba qui dentro c'è qualcosa
di nero ragazze tra parava è troppo
voglio poi non c entro di denis
oddio cosa mi stanno schiacciare
all'inizio hanno nomi sta schiacciando
si sta ok perfetto non posso più tornare
indietro non posso più tornare indietro
grandissimi una notiziona finalmente era
ora che succedesse qualcosa di te
era ora che succedette la chiave del
successo
oh mio dio dove sono cosa è successo
alla morte ma perché cos'era quella fare
ok ragazzi sono devo riuscire allora
quasi una porta chiusa devo riuscì a
scappare prima che quella fare mib il
devo riuscire maledizione cori prima non
so neanche dove è
ok adesso con dove corri corri posizione
accordi mai detto m'hai quanto manca
dove sono perché tutto nero maledizione
non voglio tirarmi la gara
non ti diranno di arti tiranno ci
diranno sì girare lo still here are
corri addio una porta di salute anche se
questo si apra pt aprite aprite aprite
aprite a brindisi ok sono fuori o mio
dio
ok si è chiuso la porta si dice però
fatto non ci credo oh mio dio invii temi
che ce l'ho fatta fatemelo capire in
qualche modo per essere diventato tutto
nero tipo una scritta una misera anche
scritto hai vinto nello beleggia
ingiusto per dare un po di soddisfazione
grazie mille
rega se l'ho fatta mi son preso tre o
quattro in quarti ma ciò non basta
[Musica]
due le mani
va bene ragazzi come al solito semi dove
piaciuto lasciate un commento mi piace
anche la pagina di facebook e come non i
video trovate nella descrizione sanchez
agonisti iscrivetevi né ci vediamo al
prossimo video belle ragazze
[Musica]